it's a great joy to be with you this
morning and I'm just thrilled to hear
the mass in real life I've listened many
times to a disc but that never compares
to the real thing let us pray may the
words of my mouth and the meditations of
all our hearts prove acceptable in your
sight o God our rock and our Redeemer
amen we here in the twentieth chapter of
acts that Paul was eager to be in
Jerusalem if possible on the day of
Pentecost now Pentecost was the festival
at which the church had really gotten it
start at which the followers of Christ
had had an extraordinary experience of
the wind and fire of the Spirit it had
mobilized their energies but now 20
chapters later or 18 chapters later we
encounter the word Pentecost again for
the only other time in the book of Acts
Paul was eager to be in Jerusalem if
possible on the day of Pentecost by now
Paul the Apostle has been jailed he's
been whipped he's been mocked he's had
great success he's had great failure and
he has extended himself farther and
farther and farther out into the known
world and he's exhausted he needs to get
back to the center he needs to renew his
spiritual energy I bet there is not one
person in this Chapel today who doesn't
know about being overextended you get
overextended in your studies you get
overextended in your rehearsal time you
get overextended in your work you get
out there and out there and out there
and finally you know you need to return
to the spear
virtual center to that place that
revitalizes who you are Paul was eager
to be in Jerusalem if possible on the
day of Pentecost there is a basic
fundamental human need that keeps
reasserting itself for spiritual renewal
anton bruckner the composer whose mass
number 2 and E minor we are about to
hear knew about this he knew about the
need to return to the spiritual center
both in his personal life and in his
artistic musical life he was raised a
devout Roman Catholic his mother had a
beautiful soprano voice and often sang
in the high masses of their church as a
little child he sat on the organ bench
next to his father who was the church
organist and indeed in time Bruckner
would grow up to be the most famous
organist of the late 19th century in
Europe sadly at age 12 his father died
and his mother realizing what a gifted
child he was was very eager for him to
get an excellent education so she placed
him in st. florian which was a monastery
that ran a school for boys and that had
a boy's choir for the masses and the
liturgies that took place there so
that's where anton bruckner grew up and
he loved it there again and again
throughout his life whenever he got over
extended he went back to st. Florian's
it was for him what Jerusalem was for
st. Paul it was the center of spiritual
renewal now this need for renewal was
something he knew not only in his
personal life but something that he
expressed in his music
as a matter of fact as I read many books
about him one of his great musicologists
who studied him extensively says st.
Florian is the perfect visual
representation of his music you actually
have a picture of the main nave on the
front of your bulletin and you can see
where he worshiped this writer talks
about the Magnificent baroque grandeur
that he knew you will hear something of
that grandeur in his music and talks
about the crypts and narrow passages in
the monastery this very haunted kind of
building and there is something haunting
about his music one critic elizabeth
meyer tries to summarize what Bruckner
is doing in his music and these are her
words she says he is attempting to
recover the lost spirituality of our
world attempting to recover the lost
spirituality of our world when I read
that it left right off the page I
thought it sounds like our age I think
of all the articles i've read about
people who are not religious but
spiritual this immense hunger that is in
the culture to recover a lost
spirituality now there is a danger in
recovering a lost spirituality the main
danger is this that we will become
antiquarians we will dress up in the
costumes of the past and carry out their
practices but none of the juice that was
originally there will be in us it will
be an empty practice Christ was very
aware of this danger and so in the
gospel this morning he describes what he
calls a scribe trained for the kingdom
he says scribes trained for the kingdom
are able to bring out of there
household treasure something new and
something old if you want an authentic
spirituality you've got to be in touch
with the past you've got to hear what
the psalmist had to say I will utter
dark sayings from of old things our
parents told us you need to know the
past but you also need to be wide open
to the spirit that blows in totally
surprising ways you need to be trained
so that you can bring out something old
and something new and if ever if ever
there were a composer who was a scribe
trained for the kingdom it was Anton
Bruckner he spent almost the first up to
his 40th birthday nearly studying and
studying and studying the great masters
of the past he was drenched in plainsong
enchant and in polyphony and in his
music he draws upon all of these old
forms as a matter of fact we'll see in
the Sanctus he actually directly quotes
from them but at the same time he isn't
mired in the past he has his own
harmonic idiom you will hear some
fabulously rich harmonies he has his own
rhythmic methods patterns that are
almost not unique to him but they occur
again and again that are part of his
unique voice when you listen to the
music of Bruckner it's as though you can
hear the angels and the Archangels and
the whole company of heaven and
everybody who's here now playing
instruments and singing the whole cloud
of witnesses is gathered about you one
of his former students said of Bruckner
and I quote him he said the chords and
the associations he had with particular
cords were Brook nurse path to the
kingdom of God
think of that musical sounds as a path
to the kingdom of God there are many
many great composers who have written
magnificent sacred music who did not
have a particularly strong faith and we
give great things to God for them but
Bruckner was not among them he was a
passionate and devout believer and
practitioner of the Christian faith and
he did not separate his music from his
art they were interviewed inseparably
for him perhaps that is why the single
most common metaphor that is used in the
scholarship to describe Brooker's music
almost every single scholar Bruckner
scholar uses this word to describe his
music Cathedral they talk about the
great gothic spans of the music the
mystery off at the all the majesty of it
Harold C Cherne Berg who used to be the
New York Times music critic describes
what he calls the slow inexorable Psalm
harmonies of this Cathedral like music
the slow in X herbal solemn harmonies of
this Cathedral like music this is not
music for a digital age you can't punch
in on your iPhone you can't punch in on
your iPhone if i can find mine come Holy
Spirit and have it come it takes time
one critic says in the introduction to
his music he says let me give you a
single word of advice as you listen to
the Bruckner a single word patience
patience this music unfolds slowly when
you first come into a cathedral you
can't take the whole thing in it's
overwhelming you won't be able to take
in everything that Bruckner is
but sit there in the cathedral of his
music don't fish out your iPhone listen
this is a different way of existing it's
the way of profound prayer now I'm going
to name just one or two little details
about the music I don't want to
overwhelm you with them but it will help
you perhaps get into the spirit of it in
the Cure a there are three distinct
sections one critic describes them as
different but similar different but
similar and that's true the result is as
each new section starts it's almost like
something is evolving in your heart
almost as though your tape being carried
into no depths and heights of the mercy
for which we pray in the Curia and then
in the next section in the Gloria I want
you to listen for the difference between
the music that accompanies the words
about God and Christ and listen for the
wonderful brass fanfares almost that are
part of the accompaniment they're not
technically fanfares but they almost
feel like that there's an energy to the
music of God there's a power the music
of God which utterly contrast to the
section where they sing that they hope
God will we hope God will take away the
sins of the world and the music slows it
becomes very quiet and you can actually
feel the weight of the world in the
music it's as though in sound bruckner
is giving us the infinite qualitative
difference between the divine and our
broken world are burdened world and the
music is saying there is a source of
energy and power that can help this burn
the world be lifted up that's what he's
saying with the music so I invite you
now to to enter
this Cathedral I invite you to celebrate
the mystery that Bruckner celebrates i
invite you to return to the wellspring
of eternal grace an eternal life i
invite you to go back to Jerusalem and
time for Pentecost and to be touched by
the wind and the flame of the Holy
Spirit